[ __ ] up I'm gonna say well that's the
intro for you but if you deepen you in
here hey what is going on YouTube now
you know I was gonna say some [ __ ] about
this why because well I'm an opinionated
[ __ ] would you expect and you
know what we're here to talk about right
oh no I didn't yes I did yes I did not
recently for those of you who are in the
hubbub and the know about there's been a
little bit of rattle tassel in Indiana I
don't even know what rattle tassel means
now let's be real it's been all over
social media
Indiana's RFRA that has been passed and
will be actively starting but July first
use it now to cut to this to make a long
story short the whole controversy about
this is that the RFRA bill is going to
allow the residents of Indiana to act in
a legalized form of discrimination
against the LGBT community so to dumb it
down even further basically how people
are going to use this law is I own a
burger shop company but not if you're a
queer hallelujah so for the fun of it
let's talk about both sides of the coin
for a moment from a religious standpoint
business owners are saying that is wrong
for them to be forced to do something
that infringes on their religious rights
from the LGBT perspective you cannot
refuse service to me because of my
lifestyle because that is a form of
discrimination religious rights versus
human rights so for me all I can say is
are you [ __ ] kidding me okay to play
devil's advocate let's just say you're
trying to force a pastor to marry you
somehow first of all that [ __ ] doesn't
even make sense so it doesn't even
matter because my stuff like this seeps
through you have to ask yourself when
does this kind of [ __ ] really end how is
it still that in this day and age there
are still people out there that are
trying to legalize forms of
discrimination [ __ ] those days
are over
try to refuse me service [ __ ] you'll
get to the back of the bus
[ __ ] your railroad line building that
[ __ ] do you realize that there are way
bigger problems on this earth than to
deal with you hateful [ __ ] and
your homophobia California don't got no
water damn it you have a dab the
swimming pool filled with rocks for
example there was an article talking
about the first pizza parlor in Indiana
that is starting to review service to
the LGBT community and all I have to say
to that is get what [ __ ] you think
you are what a [ __ ] wants to get
and your date as heck [ __ ] back
to last is upon a [ __ ] the fact that
you even offer that [ __ ] as a service to
gay or straight people is an abomination
I dare you to find one gay person to say
oh you know what we gonna do we go get
married in this Busta - pizza shop
fabula what the [ __ ] do you care and I
hate it when people do the [ __ ] and they
suddenly just deny all the bigotry and
hate that comes along with it I'm not
discriminate against anyone I have my
all right listen you hateful ass [ __ ]
if you're gonna be a bigot at least own
up to its [ __ ] you know what let's get
even a little bit religious on this oh
no watch it
yes from a religious standpoint
homosexuality is a sin by sure as [ __ ]
don't remember a Bible verses saying
thou shalt not feed the gays no I
remember the Christian religion being a
religion of love Jesus can't do with
that non-discriminating lifestyle and
taking everybody if they did believe
hallelujah penny you forgot love that
name a [ __ ] hallelujah and even beyond
that do you think that pushing and
segregating other people away from your
religion is going to help them get
closer to you all I know for a fact is
that you're not Asian there is not a
single ancient person that owns a
business that would turn a customer way
if they spend the money we don't give a
[ __ ] if you black Mexican gay lesbian or
a Jewish [ __ ]
if you got cash bring that ass even if
they didn't believe in homosexuality
watch how fast that [ __ ] would change
hello we're gay dipper hell out we have
cash right now I don't want to pay
people who support this bill all with
malicious intent
I'm just saying that some of y'all are
misguided or stupid as [ __ ] not too long
ago color people in this country had a
similar issue if you know your history
books and yes some of that was backed
also by religion what tell them listen
you [ __ ] you not letting people eat
your pizza ain't gonna change the fact
that they're gay you know what why don't
you even think about it like this if gay
people are supporting your business
isn't that the ultimate payback
I [ __ ] hate your guts but you're
keeping my lights on so I'll wait you
bunch of queers aha checkmate right
you're [ __ ] hateful [ __ ]
that has passed and it will be not it's
going to what huh
the RFA RFA oh I'm just making up [ __ ]
now on Rockland from a religious aspect
bitmap from a religious aspect business
owners are how because of my lifestyle
because that from the LGBT perspective
you cannot pattern so let's not get into
the nitty-gritty and [ __ ] what am i
doing a Mexican action suddenly male
gaze and homosexuals and strays fighting
all the time eh [ __ ] it whatever and
they legalize form a discrimination
against the LGBT community I [ __ ] did
it